bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau 7,8 sport à lyon passe
tout de suite au sommaire dix mois après
l'ouverture du vélodrome national
l'équipe cycliste de vélizy organise son
premier grand prix sur la piste au
record pas moins de dix champions de
france seront présents ce week-end pour
le compte de la 5e journée de pro a de
tennis de table et l'encours recevait
série ce concurrent direct pour le
maintien
le faux pas était donc interdit le ctpe
n'a pas perdu la frustration a dominé il
s'appelle christophe masson depuis douze
ans il est arbitre de football amateur
nous l'avons rencontré à l'occasion des
journées nationales de l'arbitrage c'est
notre portrait de la semaine et comme
d'habitude en fin d'émission l'essentiel
des résultats du week end mais tout
d'abord place au cyclisme je le disais
dans les titres de ce sept huit sports
ce week-end le 9 le dimanche 9 novembre
le vélodrome nationale va accueillir son
premier grand prix inter régional de
cyclisme sur piste
un événement organisé par le club de
vélizy l'organisateur est présent sur le
plateau du 7-8 sports jean michel
richefort bonsoir à vous bon soin de
passer sur le 7-8 sport et notre nouveau
consultant que vous avez l'habitude
maintenant de voir yann dujarrier est
présent aussi ce soir bonsoir yann tout
d'abord première question jean michel
comment s'est créé cette idée
d'organiser enfin un premier grand prix
gens me dire sur la piste du vélodrome
oui on fait un premier grand prix parce
que nous avons eu les championnats de
france nous allons avoir les
championnats du monde et
velizy est un peu le club référent pour
la piste dans les yvelines parce que
nous n'avons pas moins de seize
pratiquants réguliers assidu au
vélodrome et et des médailles et nous
avons cette année deux champions la
france 200 plants de france 3
participants ou championnat du monde et
tout naturellement donc il était
légitime que le club que l'équipe
cycliste de vélizy organise une première
compétition pour permettre aux régionaux
mais aussi aux espoirs aux espoirs et
aux champions de demain c'est la relève
de pouvoir s'exprimer sur ce magnifique
outil qu'est le vélodrome national
difficile d'attirer aujourd'hui des
talents des des poids lourds comme on
dit un peu de la discipline sur un grand
prix comme ça non tout naturellement
nous avons des représentants de douze
comités régionaux ils viennent de
bretagne de bourgogne du nord pas de
calais de rhône-alpes et le sait
l'attirance du vélodrome ce vélodrome va
susciter forcément des vocations est
l'objectif de ce grand prix c'est de
faire naître des vocations
alors vous le disiez pas moins de dix
champions de france nous avons des
champions de france cadets des champions
de france junior et champion de france
seniors également et des champions de
france master mais dans les catégories
juniors vu le plateau qui sera présent
dimanche nous avons la relève et l'élite
de demain des gens qui vont succéder au
baugé et perd 10 moyens on peut penser
notamment à sébastien vigier
vice-champion du monde 2014 ont encore
maximilien clair ça c'est la relève yann
justement qu'on va pouvoir voir ce
week-end c'est important qu'ils
s'expriment déjà sur cette piste
qu'elles verront tous et de toutes
façons important qu'il puisse y faire
des compétitions soit championnat élite
ils ont pas été invités
c'est un petit peu dommage ça aurait
fait un peu plus de participants donc la
voix lasse et c'est la raison pour
laquelle ils répondent tous présents
venir prendre des marques l identique
pour les grands champions venir faire
une compétition sur le vélodrome pour
savoir comment ça va réagir jean michel
richefort vous parlais tout à l'heure de
faire naître des vocations
le vélodrome a dû changer beaucoup votre
quotidien au club de vélizy non
maintenant vous entraînez quasiment
exclusivement j'imagine au vélodrome oui
avant il y avait
la ci par là la fameuse l'anneau
historique
l'anneau history de paris mais il y
avait saint-denis également il avait
aulnay-sous-bois de ce sont toujours des
vélodromes des vélodromes de plein air
il y aura toujours des compétitions mais
là aujourd'hui avec un tel outil
avant on connaissait pékin moscou
manchester bien sûr qui est la mecque du
vélo mais aujourd'hui c'est vraiment un
des plus beaux sinon le plus bel outil
au monde que ce vélodrome et il serait
dommage de ne pas l'utiliser
bien sûr pour les champions pour
l'équipe de france qui s'entraîne mais
après pour pour tout le monde et nous
nous sommes à proximité de ce vélodrome
et nous venons régulièrement au moins
deux fois par semaine sans traîner sur
sur ce vélodrome
et d'ailleurs nous allons faire un
entraînement hivernal et quelquefois que
lorsqu'il fait mauvais dehors il est
préférable de faire une belle séance
dans la grille sur la piste que de faire
une mauvaise séance dans le froid à
l'extérieur
yann votre avis d'expert sur ce sur ce
grand prix on voit des grands prix comme
par exemple les trois jours de grenoble
qui ont un peu fermé tirer le rideau
c'est une façon de relancer un peu ces
épreuves là qu'ils ont du mal à exister
à subsister
pour l'instant c'est une première on en
parle et rit jean michel ça peut être un
objectif pour pour la suite c'est vrai
qu'il faut il faut relancer on a un très
bel outil
ça peut apporter des annonceurs donc
voilà ça peut être un objectif à se
fixer pour pour les années à venir et
relancer un grand prix sur le juste sur
le secteur français puisque qu'on nomme
était le dernier quand on voit le
programme de ce week-end
il ya beaucoup d'épreuves d'endurance il
ya évidemment cette démonstration de
vitesse à laquelle vous allez participer
yalin il faut il faut le dire donner un
petit peu de dents vie aux
téléspectateurs c'est difficile de faire
cohabiter toutes ces épreuves dans un
timing aussi série qui est une après
midi pour pouvoir faire de la vitesse de
la course aux points etc
non c'est une question de
d'organisation de timing et je pense que
tout est calculé pour donner du rythme
parce que la piste c'est spectaculaire
par a par définition que ce soit la
vitesse les épreuves d'endurance
également parce que il y à des attaques
des contre attaques le caring tout ça
c'est il y aura pas de kering mai cédait
très spectaculaire après il faut rythme
et les différentes courses les
différentes catégories
et là c'est un uniquement un problème
d'organisation mais nous allons y faire
face sans aucun problème c'est cette
épreuve qu'est le grand prix ce week-end
est ce que c'est une façon aussi pour
les jeunes de montrer un peu ce qui
s'affairent au au stade de des équipes
de france de l'insep etc
oui c'est important parce que nous avons
des pensionnaires
du pôle france de l'insep mais nous
avons des juniors comme jeudi et des
cadets et là il ya un engouement parce
que la piste c'est l'apprentissage c'est
l'école du vélo par excellence
et ça commence au niveau est tout jeune
et notamment au niveau des cadets et là
nous sommes fiers d'accueillir pas moins
de 30 cadets et des cadets qui viennent
de toute la france des cadets qui
viennent de bretagne qui viennent du
limousin qui viennent du nord pas de
calais et ça c'est un peu notre
satisfaction de permettre à ces jeunes
de venir s'exprimer devant des cadres
techniques qui seront d'île de france
bien sûr mais des cadres techniques de
la fédération française de cyclisme a
bien merci beaucoup jean michel
richefort d'être passés sur les 7,8
sport et donc ouverture des portes ce
dimanche 13h15 et puis après on pourra
voir évidemment toutes les toutes les
compétitions qui sont au programme et si
je peux me permettre l'entrée est
gratuite
c'est parfait c'est noté en tout cas
pour tous les passionnés on va rester
avec nous on va continuer à parler de
cyclisme puisque yann dujarrier présence
ce soir sur le plateau du 7-8 fort
puisque il y a eu les championnats
d'europe yann qui ont eu lieu il ya
quelques jours et toute la délégation
française n'était pas présente un
puisque françois pervis n'était pas en
guadeloupe mais d'autres d'autres pistes
arrêter là notamment quentin lafargue
qui a cette médaille de bronze sur le
kilomètre on en parlait justement après
les championnats de france il avait
impressionné en vitesse là il s'est un
petit peu loupé c'est votre avis j'étais
pas là bas j'ai pas vu les j'ai pas vu
les courses je les ai pas vu non plus
elle a le déroulé du tournoi je trouve
dommage que quinze jours après un
championnat de france où il a été
presque dire dominateur on ait remporté
la qualification et le et le titre le
titre sur la vitesse je trouve dommage
qu'ils soient pas au même niveau sur un
championnat d'europe ou grégory baugé
s'impose
et donc voilà quentin lafargue là
dommage de ne pas avoir réussi à passer
le petit cap pour pour dire au niveau
international je suis encore ici dont il
parlait d'ailleurs ce cap un os à notre
micro lors des championnats de france
vous parliez de grégory baugé en or sur
la vitesse c'est une façon de marquer un
petit peu son territoire avant les
championnats du monde à chocolat du
monde avait jugé pas beaucoup d'onglets
en finale et donc contre contre un
allemand qu'on connaît depuis depuis
très très longtemps
forsman ouais il se rappelle à tout le
monde je suis je suis là j'ai des
objectifs vous n'oubliez pas mon dommage
on aurait bien vu à ce niveau
international une petite confrontation
françois pervis s'est tu rigoles oui ça
sera pour sûrement le mois de février au
vélodrome national de saint-quentin
imminent je vous le rappelle les les
mondiaux seront à saint quentin en
yvelines en 2015 en attendant il y avait
donc ces championnats d'europe y avait
aussi la vitesse par équipes une
victoire allemande
on sait sûrement que ce sera le grand
rival de l'équipe de france sur les
mondiaux moi je n'oublie pas
l'angleterre
l'angleterre qui est toujours présent
quand il faut presque est ce que les
championnats du monde en france seront
un objectif pour eux ça on verra en
temps et en heure mais il faut savoir
aussi je pense que l'équipe qui est
indigne au championnat d'europe ne sera
peut-être pas la même que celle qui sera
signé d'un championnat du monde
parce que là l'équipe française s'était
donc michael d'almeida kévin sireau et
grégory baugé qui avait terminé deuxième
aux jeux olympiques à londres
je pense qu'il serait intéressant et je
pense que griffon que françois pervis
sera sera intégré à cette équipe et on
risque de monter d'un niveau c'est le
grand débat d'ailleurs au sein de
l'équipe de france 1 où on va se situer
à quelle place aussi va évoluer
françois pervis lors de ces championnats
du monde la bonne surprise sur ces
championnats d'europe c'est benjamin
thomas qui remporte la course aux points
il n'était pas très attendue en finale
dans ces championnats d'europe are 4e 4e
au championnat de france
quinze jours avant et la wii gagner ils
dominent parce que il a remporté cinq
classements si c'est ce que tu m'aimais
mes recherches sont bonnes remporter
cinq classements il avait gagné la
course 4 avant fin mai il a fait
troisième mode est alors enfin captation
de l'arrivée et après derrière il prend
plus de points il avait déjà remporté le
titre vraiment une très belle une très
belle domination et une belle une belle
surprise
quinze jours après un championnat de
france où il était resté
au pied du podium oui souvent au pied du
podium lors de ces gens biens français
votre petit coup de coeur c'est laurie
berton sur ces championnats d'europe
pour quelle raison parce qu'une deuxième
place au championnat de france
alors je crois que c'était en course à
points elle marque beaucoup de points
mais elle manque d'aller chercher un
tour avec là je suis qui avait pris un
prix un tour chez des filles à ce moment
là et là ben pareil et une belle seconde
place sur 1 sur un championnat d'europe
au scratch et un petit peu la même alors
beau sprint simplement à l'arrivée et
dommages et a une fille qui a pris un
tour donc du coup elle du coup il lui
manque un élément que ça peut-être là le
fait d'aller chercher chercher la course
pendant la course mais voilà je pense
que là il ya une belle fonde au sein de
l'équipe de france est et qui parce
qu'elle est très jeune elle est très
jeune c'est vrai que le rimeur temps
c'est sûrement la relève de l'équipe de
france dernière question ces champions
d'europe pour vous c'était une façon de
continuer de préparer déjà les les
mondes qui seront à saint quentin en
yvelines en 2015 on est trop loin on ait
trouvé trop lointaine ingla les coupes
du monde qui vont arriver vont commencer
vraiment à établir plus une hiérarchie
au sein l'équipe de france est vraiment
une vraie préparation pour pour le final
de février très bien merci beaucoup et
yann d'être passés sur le 7-8 sport
consultant donc cyclisme pour l'émission
et vous vous allez maintenant vous
préparer pour cette pensée des chauves
la vitesse de dimanche donc au vélodrome
nationale allez on passe au tennis de
table
pour le compte de la 5e journée de pro a
de tennis de table locaux recevaient
serris un concurrent direct pour le
maintien il faut le dire le faux pas
était donc interdit le ctt eux n'a pas
perdu mais la frustration a dominé
montage de romain rugby face à un
concurrent direct pour le maintien
elancourt n'avais pas vraiment le droit
à l'erreur au palais des sports un temps
gêné par la défense de son adversaire
en bon fer de lance yanan wang et ses
coups droits dévastateurs offre le
premier point aux sept étaient eux pas
en rythme eva odorova mais trois sets
pour trouver le bouton du réveil est
réglé la mire les saint-quentinoises
font le break 2 à 0 alors quand voudrait
arrive s'approche de la table on se dit
qu'elle en cours pourraient avoir
presque match gagné à la pause avec
trois points
mais c'était sans compter sur l'autre
soeur air délit qui prolonge le suspense
et fait monter la tension d'un cran
2 1 pour elle en cours après la pause
les joueuses de franck soulier se
rapproche du but grâce au deuxième
succès d'eva odorova au prix de poing
titanesque comme cet échange de 30 et
une frappe
point pour elle en cours derrière malgré
un combat acharné en cinq sets yann
allemande fini par rendre les armes face
à une ana maria air d'élite pourtant
blessé à la main droite c'est finalement
pauline chasselin qui arrache
logiquement le match nul face à une
audrey zarif peu inspiré et l'encours
doit partager les points avec serris si
dans les autres matches de la journée
les résultats sont favorables et
permettent au club de conserver sa
cinquième place
la frustration domine dans le contenu je
suis un peu déçu quoi y avait des choses
quand même sur les deux derniers matches
à faire et puis on n'a pas réussi
donc bon ben c'est comme ça quand il va
falloir réfléchir un petit peu là dessus
revoir un peu à la vidéo et puis re
parler un peu des matches à domicile
parce que je pense qu'il va falloir
qu'on quand même con qu'on arrive à
s'imposer un peu un peu chez nous quoi
jusqu'au 6 novembre prochain est
organisée la 13e édition des journées
nationales de l'arbitrage et à cette
occasion nous avons rencontré christophe
masson il est arbitre de football
amateur assez expérimentés qui officiait
ce week end dans un championnat le
championnat du dimanche matin
reportage réalisé avec yolande thorez et
elodie moines comme presque chaque
dimanche christophe masson chose ses
crampons mais depuis 12 ans ce passionné
de football suit les matches
le sifflet à la main au centre du
terrain je suis pas 3 mètres près ce qui
m'intéresse c'est la reprise du jeu la
rapidité de la reprise du jeu cet ancien
gardien de but est venu à l'arbitrage
par passion et non pas pour y gagner sa
vie qui arrive perçoit seulement un
défraiement kilométrique
à 50 ans il prend le sifflet jusqu'à
trois fois par semaine pour oublier le
stress du travail
mais au fil des saisons il a vu évoluer
le comportement des joueurs
les joueurs sont de plus en plus tendue
je pense que c'est lié à leur condition
personnelle certainement à travers le
travail je ressens depuis au moins deux
ans des gens
des joueurs plus énervé moins patients
d'ailleurs moi même je suis aussi
affecté par sa face à la veuve de crise
on sent déjà un petit peu plus tendue
l'oeil toujours rivé sur le ballon ce
chef d'entreprise voit le football comme
un sport en mouvement où le jeu doit
être fluide
larbitre ne doit jamais cassé le rythme
son rôle c'est d'être toujours en
harmonie avec le jeu d'être compris il
faut favoriser la communication pendant
le match avec des échanges bref ça
permet aux joueurs de se situer par
rapport aux lois du jeu et la direction
du match par l'arbitrage
on souhaite que les arbitres soient
plutôt animateur de jeu en 2002 alors
qu'il arbitrait un match à plaisir
christophe a assisté un règlement de
comptes sur le terrain après avoir
sifflé une faute
depuis il prévient et explique toujours
ces sanctions pour vous ce sera la
dernière
cette faute-là l'obstruction qui
l'empêchent d'aller au but on est
d'accord il excentré soit mais attention
c'est la dernière pour vous ce jour là
christophe des livres quatre cartons
jaunes
la rencontre remportée par l encours un
but à zéro se déroule sans aucun
problème vous garder le ballon
maintenant il est toujours difficile
surtout avec nous qui parlons beaucoup
c'est difficile de garder son sang froid
quand on a ravi 3
là en tout cas aujourd'hui il a fait son
job un match plutôt sympathique
quelques conflits mais pas plus que
d'habitude
le jeu s'est un peu plus celui ci en
deuxième mi temps mais quand même
beaucoup de contestations c'est ça aussi
le foot amateur
le district de football des yvelines
dispose de trois cent dix arbitres ils
étaient 135 nageurs dans le bassin de
maurepas ce week-end au sixième meeting
des maîtres de saint quentin en yvelines
ce rendez-vous désormais incontournable
qui ouvre la saison des masters est
aussi qualificatif pour les championnats
de france qui vont s'est déroulée en
mars prochain
au total vingt clubs étaient représentés
le plus vieux nageurs tenez vous bien
dans le bassin avait 81 ans le quoi
qu'il en soit ce meeting des maîtres
permettent aux nageurs confirmés de
prendre parfois certains repères pour le
reste de la saison
il ya des temps s'il ya des nages ou qui
sont croyants qualifiés pour les
championnats de france
donc ils viennent chercher une première
qualif et si toutefois la qualif
ils n'ont pas passé leur bac permet
avant le mois de mars d'aller sur doute
métier pour les chercheurs
notre qualif allez on enchaîne avec
l'essentiel des résultats du week-end
et ce dimanche vous avez dû suivre le
départ de la 10e édition de la route du
rhum pourquoi parce que nous suivons
évidemment l'épopée de tanguy de lamotte
vous le savez ce marin versailles et qui
mais qui n'a pas échappé à l'hécatombe
davari de ses premières 24 heures vers
10 heures ce lundi 3 novembre et suite à
un choc initiative coeur endommagé son
safran bâbord après avoir assuré le
contournement du rail de cars go away
sans tanguy de lamotte a fait un état
des lieux dans une mer assez mouvementée
tanguy est en train de faire demi tour
pour faire une escale pour réparer son
bateau une avarie survenue à un moment
où le marin versailles et était dans le
wagon de tête à la 5e place de la classe
imoca
à suivre en football retour sur terre et
pour le compte de la 7e journée de
division d'honneur versailles n'a rien
pu faire sur la pelouse de créteil
lusitanos défaite 2 buts à 0 et avec
cette troisième défaite de la saison les
versaillais conservent tout de même leur
troisième place au classement avec 17
points créteil conforte sa première
place avec 26 points en promotion
d'honneur trap a fait un bon match nul
ce week-end face aux troisièmes parisy
score final un but partout et avec ce
résultat vous allez le voir au
classement trappe gagne petit places et
se retrouve avec 11 points au sixième
rang à six longueurs du leader jeunes
villiers en basket les matches se
suivent et se ressemblent
malheureusement pour l'entente le
chesnay versailles pour le compte de la
7ème journée de nationale 2 les joueuses
de vinko bar dit je recevais à bel air
le quatrième le poinçonnet dans un match
qui a vu un nombre important de shoots
ratés que vous voyez à l'écran
d'ailleurs les yvelinoises se sont une
nouvelle fois inclinés 48 à 34 un tout
petit score
avec cette septième défaite en autant de
matches du lcv restent scotchés dans les
bas fonds du classement de sa poule à la
11e place chez les hommes nationale 3
évidemment 7e journée également est sale
week-end pour les club yvelinois trappe
s'incline face au leader gennevilliers
89 à 59 et de son côté le lcv n'a pas
pesé
exister à vineuil défaite 85 à 68 et
vous allez le voir au classement pas de
gros changement il faut le dire
gennevilliers est toujours leader devant
poissy trappe pointe désormais au
septième rang dans la deuxième partie de
tableau de son côté le fcv tenu à une
sinistre 11e place avec 7 points
comme tous les ans au 1er novembre
plaisir organise son traditionnel open
de pétanque et c'était la 29e édition
cette année parmi les centaines de
doublettes présentes une paire
yvelinoise familiale tenter sa chance
lionel le mari est tireur viviane la
pointeuse il était venu jouer à plaisir
pour prendre du plaisir sur le
boulodrome et se mêler à la convivialité
1 de l'open ils se sont inclinés lors de
leur deuxième partie de la journée
samedi ont été reversés en consolante
mais pas de quoi se faire la tête par sa
seconde joueurs préférés et et puis on
s'entend très bien on a plein de
complicité et donc
ça fait une bonne bonne équipe à nous on
est un code pour un couple fusionnel et
non au contraire on se booste on se
motive on s'encourage
et puis voilà ça marche ou ça ne marche
pas hélas ça n'a pas marché
allez un dernier résultat avant de
passer à votre agenda du week-end et du
volleyball quatrième défaite consécutive
pour montigny lors de la 6e journée de
régionale une lésigny montain se sont
inclinés sèchement à villejuif 3 sets à
0 il pointe désormais à la huitième
place
place à votre agenda du week-end je le
disais tout d'abord du cyclisme on en
parlait tout à l'heure dans notre page
spéciale grand prix de vélizy ce
dimanche 9 novembre au vélodrome
national de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
celle il y aura évidemment un des
champions de france sur le plateau et
ouverture des portes à partir de 13h15
du handball le retour de la team
soixante dix huit pour le championnat de
france des moins de 18 ans et c'est le
choc de cette 6e journée à ne pas
manquer entre le team 78 en ballet paris
galaxie les joueurs d'alexandre
taillefer se sont inclinés il faut le
dire il faut le rappeler au match aller
à paris et ont à coeur de prendre leur
revanche au gymnase mont boron de
versailles coup d'envoi ce samedi à 17
heures c'est la fin de ce set 8 faut
remercier encore une fois de l'avoir
suivi on se retrouve lundi prochain même
lieu même heure d'ici là excellente
soirée sur tv